年前に学習サービスを立ち上げたとき
世界中の学習コンテンツを集めを頃思いました
さあ動画学習コンテンツ集めようかそう思ったとターン
すぐに大きな疑問にぶち当たりました
そもそも
学習コンテンツとは一体何なのでしょ
オンライン上には今やたまざまなコンテンツがあふれています
そこであるものは学習コンテンツまた別のものは学習用ではない肌のコンテンツを
開けるとしたらその腕を者の違いは一体何なのでしょう
具体的な例を見ていきますのでみなさんも一緒に考えてみてください
まずはこちらです
夢なかったですね
平和を教えている youtube 動画です
これは学習コンテンツでしょうか
それともただのコンテンツでしょうか
音なく学習コンテンツず読んでいいと思う
続いてこちらです
プログラミングの tips が書かれた後ライブの近影
これは学習コンテンツでしょうか
あの頃だと思う
フェイっ
に神のメール
ちゃん持っん
これは学習訓練でしょうか
パラもんですでしょうか聞いてみましょう学習コンテンツの思う方が手を挙げてみて
ください
ありがとうございますほんじゃなくてただのコンテンツだと思われる方を上げてみて
ありがとうございますのコーリャン半くらいになりますね続嬉しいですうん
細胞
日本シリーズの結果の new これ w コンテんでしょうか
ハム違うんだと思う
さて3つ目の夫のツイートですがあれ学習コンテンツなのかどうかというのが人によっ
てことなりました
つまり学習コンテンツがそうでないコンテンツなのか
この教会というのは非常にあいまいです白黒呆れることができません
むしろこのようにコンテンツだけを見て学習コンテンツ the
そうじゃないのか
これを判断すること自体何が間違ってるのかもしれません
例えばもちろん
一冊の本があります
タイトルは代数的整数論
数学の大学も空学の教科書で生
教科書ですから
明らかに学習コンテンツだと思われるんでしょ
ただこれは僕にとって今の僕にとっては学習本店ではありません
残念ながら何が書いてあるのかさっぱりわからないからん
またここに間違った面があります
af
一切の向こうから書いてきました
今の言えるを買っているかもしれません思いません
こちらまじは一切ありません
これも何分たったら学習本展示ではありません
辛いうさぎじゃないから何を学べばいいのか
やっぱりわからないからねん
ただ数学科の学生の皆さんならこの迷鳥と呼ばれる教科書からさまざまなことを学べる
ことでしょ
また僕も1歳の息子はこのて何から
a
泥遊びをする楽しさですとかシーソーする
話したこれを航行することを学ぶことができるでしょ
つまりで学習コンテンツなのかそうでないのかというのは本店つだけでは決まらないと
いうことです
その時必ずこれを受け取るがが学ぶ日てというのが飛んだします
その人がどんな状況なのか
その関係性の中で学習コンテンツなのか
ただのコンテンツなのかというのが決まってくると言えません
そして学習コンテンツの人の出会いが発生した時ある変化が起こります
これは今までなく集コンテンツとは思えなかったものが学習コンテントして受け入れ
られるようになるということです
例えば足山を見たことがない分分を聞いたことがない
そんな方にとってはが来て分布の足し算
どんなにどんなに分かりやすく教えるコンテンツがあっても学習コンテンツではあり
ません
ただ
足ダンの考え方を学んで
の概念を理解すれば
の足し算を教えるコンテンツは学習コンテンツとして
ll ことができます
代数的ですけども僕も市場陛下が基本線として受け入れられる
かませいぬん
このようにあることを学ぶことで別の何かを学ぶことができる
今まで見えなかった景色が見えるようになってくる
何かを学ぶということはこの学習本店の階段を登っていくここ
言えるかもしれません
ただここでまた一つ疑問がを生じます
さまざまな分野でこのような学習コンテンツの階段がたくさんあると考えていいの
でしょうか
その階段を守ることだけが学ぶことだと言ってしまっていいのでしょうか
もちろん英語初級中級拾生上級
特番ココアが難点ですとか it リテラシーが吹いた海でほか経済に疎いうわ c
なんていう言い方をします
奴があるうん
本来学習コンテンツ群はもっとネットワーク上につながったものです
皆さんもある本を読んでいてこれが別の分野の話とつながっている
そういう習慣はない子
僕自身もともとのバックグラウンドは分子生物学です
今は it 系の会社を起業していますけども
ただページながら初めは1人でやっていた仕事を2人3人でやっていくようになったり
うんターンしたりという様子を見ていくも3歳での性別が軍隊になり
た細胞生物かしてパック細胞に分化していくそんなことを思い出すことがある
愛車お前はさんまふうに見ているのは一つ悪いなどと思われる方もいらっしゃるかも
しれませんがここで言いたいことは
ですからレベルにもつながりこれだけが学習今でもつながりではないと言う
もっと自由に縦横無尽に習ったネットワークの方を
この方が学習訓練つながりをよく表してい
そしてこのネットワークの上では一つの先生との出会い方も持っ
自由なもん
そのために私たちが見えてるか肋骨子
すべくられないん
ジャガー年前に私たちができるんだろ
ターナーの日目
父の地図と呼ばれる画面に丸い形で学習コンテンツが表示されています
本店の方が来てないのでとても小さなチューブになってい
サーブのリリースだと利用者の方からインターでも起きたところ
1な件良子
の方は iko さんなんかでバイケーオ
するために活用したんですがたまたまをなリングプログラミングの本がある
たまたま興味を持って行ってみたら面白かったので
裏面語を学習している
学習設営コンテンツネットはなどではこのような偶然ラン6起こるん
もちろんふぁい男女に学ぶ事が悪い事だとは言いません
意味は高いところからでないと見えないのもありますし
考える力を養うためにもこのファインダーものぼるくんでそれ必要もありません
ただ僕は過去でしゅ商品座員はこの山登り
アイアンを上るここだけが学ぶべきことではないということです
例えば2点でいるように励んだこれも大事ですけれども
大学のカリキュラムを行うこと
プログラムがもなっていてもこれだけがナビではありません
もっと自由な日が来るようにいろいろ考える様々なもので会え
発見していく予定
これが教育接戦ができる前ない女にの学級から線のこの
が割合方なんではないか僕は思います
まだまだごま実名を張ってください free
youtube もうがこれは学習コンテンツでしょうか
それともまだのホームページ
もちろん入荷も時代には youtube はなかったわけです
なかったわけですけれども
いうのはこの映像からリンゴが落ちる読んだら
も配り発見大きな学びを引き出すことができました
こちら本当は気からこそところを撮りたかったんですけれども
近所の公園で撮ったので怪しまれるといけないんだ
今から持っ
また a 3時モリ先生が入居の話をなぜてきてこれか服は皇帝っていくつでしょうね
ただこのような偶然が大胆
偶然な形のられる
そしてバイキン
社会が大きく変わることによって教育程度の見直しが図られています
ただし意気なことに東京一定の階段を丁寧に来れば来るほどお好みから外れる中の白4
名が待つ待つ大異変になってきてい
そしてそこにオンラインで学ぶことの可能性があるのではないかと僕は思っ
オンラインの世界 web の世界へ web ページを構成するのは愛パーティを
まあプラグ html
アイパーテキスト山なぜからのテキストじゃなくてハイパーん
テキストなのだという今日
のろしがこれぞれながらやっていることがアイパーなのだというふうに言われています
このような様々なものが web ページ等延命寺が
に触れるならず大世界これ
学習本店でも流れは世界とよ
見ています
そして今この web の世界の学習の融合がとてねね動いて程度で済んでいます
大学のカリキュラムが今ライン配信されたり
企業の研修がオンラインで実施されたりしています
そこで止まってはいけません
でもの本来の国定であるコンテンツとコンテンツの人気によってあるいは
放射レビューに代表されるオンライン上での1棟ほどこの海上読んで
カリキュラムマーカー所法廷していないような渡航本店の出会い
これら論文誇る空間をつくっていくことが必要です
ニュートンの発展がそこら中で存在これようなそんな世界は私たちの形での未来なん
じゃないか
僕はの心理を
あれ
はぁ